I guess you guys haven't heard about me
I'm about sick of always having to buy
new clothes
you
sweet Christmas youtubers is Charlie
don't you just hate having to buy new
clothes all the time
who else fell out of their chair when
they saw this teaser you won't find it
if you search on Netflix they'll
probably make it a little easier to find
in the next couple of weeks most of
their energy is gonna be spent promoting
daredevil season 2 but Mike Colter was
at the premiere the New York premiere
for daredevil season 2 talking a little
bit about it like oh it's gonna be
badass daredevil season 2 very badass
Luke Cage badass in a slightly different
way but still just as badass I love how
that king of the town song is playing
over that if you haven't seen some of
the teaser images that they posted they
posted this promo image and it just
shows you that the series is gonna
mostly take place in Harlem it'll also
take place in Hell's Kitchen
well pricey some Jessica Jones stuff
following up on that series but unlike
daredevil which is mostly localized to
Hell's Kitchen Luke Cage is gonna jump
around the city just a little bit if
you've never been to Manhattan before
kind of here's here's where everything
is so you have Central Park in the
middle the Avengers Tower is in Midtown
Hell's Kitchen is right over here on the
east side just down a little bit lower
and then way up north of the park is
Harlem so that's what this promo image
is letting you know that a lot of stuff
is going to be happening there there are
a couple comic book characters we know
they're doing including cottonmouth
shades misty Knight which is actually
pretty big one and then Mariah Dillard
being played by alfre woodard I'm
actually really excited about that she's
actually one of the lead female roles
she'll be kind of like the jeryn hogarth
of the series the really big character
in the comics that winds up being a
villain for the Heroes for Hire talking
about Danny ran and Luke Cage teaming up
together Danny Rand of course we know is
being played by Finn Jones from Game of
Thrones that series is gonna start
shooting in April so because they've
already finished all of Luke Cage for
the most part they're really just
editing it down maybe doing a few pickup
shots I'm not expecting iron fist to
appear during Luke Cage unless it's some
kind of post-credit scene will probably
see some Jessica Jones stuff we might
see some daredevil stuff I don't really
want to get into spoilers for daredevil
yet because you may not have seen all
those episodes but I'll at least say
that there are references like verbal
references to things that happen in the
other series so there's definitely a
continuity even though we won't see them
all standing together on screen until
defenders all the Luke Cage episodes are
dropping September 30th so we might see
a full trailer for it in the next couple
of weeks but because Marvel has Captain
America Civil War coming up apply trying
to take advantage of all
type and shove a whole bunch of new
Netflix stuff in our faces like a bunch
of Iron Fist bunch of Luke Cage stuff
but they'll mostly be promoting Luke
Cage after Daredevils done so if they do
take anything to comic-con it's probably
going to be Luke Cage specific here's
what you guys need to do if you haven't
finished it finish watching daredevil
season two I'll be making videos for all
the episodes I just posted my first
video just a little while ago then if
you haven't yet go back and watch
jessica jones and that will give you the
setup for Marvel's Netflix version of
Luke Cage now it's gonna be pretty close
to the comics but there are some things
that they've changed like they had to
change the Punisher a little bit because
he was a Vietnam vet in the comics but
because the TV shows happening in modern
day he's in Afghanistan vet so there are
little minor things that they've tweaked
but as you can see from the teaser and
if you watch Jessica Jones you have a
pretty good sense for what the
characters like it's just that we don't
know a lot of his backstory yet and
that's what the Luke Cage series is for
in terms of powers he's pretty
comparable to Jessica Jones level
strength maybe a little bit stronger but
the really cool thing is that he has
indestructible skin so I don't I don't
think he has quite the jumping ability
of Jessica Jones they do try to
differentiate their powers even though
they're both really strong Jessica Jones
has some different powers in the comics
they're just like a few minor things as
they've changed but because Luke Cage is
a super-powered individual expect his
series to do more with powers but
amongst the different defenders series
it's kind of like flash and arrow like
the arrow characters don't have a lot of
powers so you don't see a lot of powers
on that TV show on flash Barry Allen has
powers so you see a lot of villains with
superpowers so just expect more that
with Luke Cage and when we get to iron
fist I cannot wait to see full-blown
magic it's gonna be really interesting
to see the way they do his powers Madame
Gao probably going to be like the
kingpin of that series what's gonna
happen next is there's a whole bunch of
batman vs superman footage the drop so
i'll probably make a video for that
there'll be some new Game of Thrones and
then Walking Dead is tomorrow night so
if you guys haven't seen it yet there's
some youtube weirdness happening right
now you can click here for my first
daredevil Easter egg video it's just
episodes 1 through 3 and you can click
here for all my Captain America Civil
War videos thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
yeah